[Music]
i can't wait forever
i'm not that patient i've got too many
things to do you're comfy like a sweater
but when the sun comes out
i won't be needing you
your smile conceals a secret
and it's so sickly sweet that i can't
see the point of taking deeper
and through a surface that is just so
beautiful
[Music]
i don't wanna spoil your soul
[Music]
your eyes make me feel dizzy
when you quiz me on my
childhood history i'll share with you if
you so
kindly cut me
[Music]
but instead i enjoy this view that
[Music]
i don't wanna spoil my soul
[Music]
would you disagree would you only see
them now right here's where we both
[Music]
i can't wait
[Music]
like a sweater
but when the sun comes out
i won't be needing
[Music]
[Music]
this is just the story of a girl who
sold her heart
she needed to forget she needed a fresh
start
be careful what you say cause she no
longer feels the same look at her eyes
and she sustains my love
once we
watch to regain the time she lost
wind is about like seconds since both
your pets crossed
sorted for a sweater keeping out this
cold weather body heat keeps her warm
but it won't last forever
she likes to think
she's clever
sold it for our nickels or your worth
when you're so fickle handed over her
heart felt it heavy and brittle
sold it for a key to regain her dignity
stored all in a box signed by yours
truly
[Music]
do
[Music]
hello everybody
welcome back to another stream
uh i was gonna stream more adam week but
then the unthinkable happens and animal
crossing new horizons
got its long-awaited update today
instead of i think it was supposed to be
friday before
so
i got extremely excited and i was like
you know what i think i'm gonna have to
play this tonight so
here's a little treat for you animal
crossing
how is everyone doing hey bergie
hey jamie
[Music]
oh i'm actually i'm actually so excited
for this it's been
a week in work i mean i think every week
is really difficult in work now it's
it's like the build up to christmas this
happens a lot in like work environments
they're like everyone's gonna be away
for a few weeks at christmas so we must
work really really hard but
it's just uh
so this update coming out was
just the cherry that i needed just yeah
it made me made me very happy very happy
and i instantly updated it and i can't
wait to play it
hey frank how was your week well i just
i just answered very hectic because you
know christmas is coming and lots of
work to be done but this makes it all
worthwhile
what was that what what did i do
i don't know hey clay
welcome back welcome welcome
back
uh yeah so let's let's just get right
into the game so
i know a few of the updates i've been
trying to
well i did watch the nintendo video but
i i
didn't watch it like intently because i
kind of want some a lot of stuff to be
um
you know just
left up to surprise but i do know that
we're getting brewster back in the cafe
so that's
exciting so let's go see i've been
playing uh more animal crossing lately
because of halloween and i didn't play
it last halloween so it's been quite
exciting but i still have a lot of my
island that i just don't know what to do
with so i'm hoping with this new update
and any things that come with this
update um i can
find more stuff to populate my little
island
[Music]
um
i was going to say something i forgot oh
yes i also brought a
aminbo card for a little villager called
russia which was my favorite villager
when i was a kid on the really old
animal crossing game on the ds i adored
russia and now rash is on my island
[Music]
[Music]
the shop closes this is an ordinance
that i need i need the late night
ordinance so i can play this game
later at night
uh jasmine that's me
i am listening
[Music]
[Music]
there are lots of uninhabited islands
other and can only be reached
yes because it's mushroom season and i
want to get all those mushroom diys
[Applause]
mysterious doesn't it these boat tours
are available once a day
residents should head down to the isle
of pierre and speak to the boat
i always wondered what the island pier
was for that's all for today have a fun
day okay quick let's run let's run and
look at the um store because the store
closes at uh nine oh thank you for
letting me know about the
game audio damn that is that is a loud
game audios okay
hopefully that's a bit better for you
now let me know
i'm a cute little witchy um but yeah
we're just gonna run down to the store
because
hello please get on my way
[Music]
we're gonna run out of time now
because it's at night hey
ah i can't get through that
see what they got
[Music]
hi there welcome to able sisters where
we sell fashions made lovingly by
[Music]
to be claw one of the things that
unfortunately new horizons didn't do
very well was
gives the characters interesting
dialogue it's not as fun to talk to
characters that took horizons but
there's a lot more to do and a lot more
to decorate and more events and stuff so
that's a good thing about it but
yeah in the old games they used to be
like super sassy sometimes and actually
quite introspective as well it could get
quite dark and deep and serious uh this
was a waste of time there's nothing nice
here i've already got a lot of this
stuff oh an input
that's silly
no
okay that was wasted time i'm gonna go
back to my house now bye
no nothing caught my eye see you later
does anyone watching actually play
animal crossing
hey um
there he is this is russia guys this is
the rasha that um
i got from the amiibo card and he was my
favorite when i was a kid
um
oh hello yeah
[Music]
[Music]
i've never seen this here before
it's a tape deck for group stretching
okay let's try this
group stretching instructions there are
two play options move your body while
holding a j con or press buttons on the
controller you must be using a jk on
controller to play wait can i just now
like is
okay
when the session starts movement guides
or button prompts will be shown on the
screen follow along with the guide and
try to move with everyone else okay
if you would like to participate in
group stretching
if you have been advised to limit
physical activity or unsure about
working out choose buttons i'm not
emotional let's do this you'll use your
joy-con during group stretching hold the
joy-con in your right hand
oh wait but i've got the whole thing
here
oh well
because i've got it all in one big thing
make sure you have enough room
to move your body
keep your activity within reasonable
limits yeah whatever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's so exciting
[Music]
is she actually doing it to me or am i
just being an idiot here
ben's fine
[Music]
she's not she's not doing it to me is
she she's just doing it with them
[Music]
wait
she is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do what you want to do
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
this is the wholesome content i came for
yay good that was good that was great
fun
oh cute
i wish there was more stuff that you
could do like have a dance off or
something
but i'll take that that was cute that
was cute
hey vail why let me just go back to my
house
i need to go
find all of these
muscles i'm still in a massive depth oh
yeah i um made brushes on stars
yesterday so
they'll start to pick up
during halloween i made this into my
little carving table where i carved
pumpkins it's quite cute i think it's
got this little pumpkin chair i can't
sit on it
yeah
it's wearing
pumpkins
and i have a cauldron back there as well
where i do all my
my witchy spells
this is also an accurate portrayal of me
trying to learn to dance foxy oh it's
hilarious
jamie's like don't overdo it
i'll hurt myself i think you're doing it
too quickly
always actually just dabbing
oh my gosh
right oh yeah i did this yesterday i
gave myself a little clothes drying rack
but there's blood on the top because
i've been killing people
[Music]
oh yeah there's an update on halves
island [ __ ] there's so much to check out
okay
oh [ __ ] yeah
the fees have been reduced for the home
construction
because i'm still like 300 000 bells
away so
hopefully that's been significantly
reduced and i will be very happy about
it
[Music]
hey
actually happy diwali to you too
you killing animal crossing
[Music]
anything is possible if you have the
imagination
um
i don't know if
you have seen all of this i feel like
you probably have but
i just add little bits here and there
she found a way there was always a way
i want to make a little mushroom floor
for this room now because i i found the
diy fur and it looks so cute
so
i got this halloween bunting as well
which is like so cute
[Music]
we're going to see what outfit i can
dress up in
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
i haven't really changed much in a long
time to be honest
[Music]
okay take off my glasses uh what should
i wear
a raincoat
see i have this one
it could be a baby chick
i could be a terminator
i could be a clown
a painter
a zombie
a magician
a sexy magician
that's what i wore for halloween
basically this on halloween i was
wearing this
uh
halloween in the animal crossing world
you all know what i wore for real
halloween
i could be cutesy girly
[Music]
wait oh my god
i'm like um geez what's she called ah
why can't i remember names uh little
nightmares i'm like the little girl from
little nightmares
i'm going to wear this
that's so cute i love it
yeah little lightness
[Music]
i'm gonna take off these wings though oh
maybe put on
like i'm going harvesting
booties
cute
[Music]
beautiful
i like that outfit let's go
excuse me
why are you in my house
[Music]
uh yes
i was just trying on clothes
[Music]
you were already in my house
[Music]
through the front door
where are you
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
oh an apple
well
[Music]
oh yeah let's play a game
[Music]
tab be higher or lower
anyone want to play in the chat do you
think the next card will be higher
or lower
than a number seven
what do we think
alex is like dude needs to learn
boundaries
yeah it could have been really awkward
okay it says higher let's go higher
is this number on this card higher
[Music]
it's okay
yes
[Music]
oh yeah your house is very small
compared to mine but i don't even have
an upstairs yet most people play in the
game having upstairs don't be too
jealous but look at my hamster isn't it
cute look at this
oh and i have a big snapping turtle here
as well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
eat him
ate him
oh no oxy lost this house to that card
[Music]
your mom's tea cozy gives me a real
homey feel well yeah cause it's from my
mom
[Music]
yeah well
i'm going now so
are you just gonna stay in my house
because
i am leaving now i was on my way out
[Music]
okay bye
[Music]
[Music]
it was it was cute it was cute i'll give
him that
but we got we got stuff to do we got
stuff to
explore
i really need to sort out what the
bloody hell is happening in the front of
my house i don't like it so it's so
ugh another day what are you doing here
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll do that later
see here's my bloody lantern
because this is my spooky
[Music]
stinky forest
look we've got some halloween trees now
oh
and i do have a money
[Music]
[Music]
no i don't want to sit on it
thanks for
what's up following on the 5k
[Music]
i'm trying to grow more black lilies so
i can
have this place oh no i don't have a
water again full of black lilies but
we're getting there and i'm probably
going to get rid of this pumpkin patch
because i've already got one but we need
to find a farming bit anyway because i
know we can farm a lot more things now
so that's great
we're keeping on the eye keep a lookout
for mushy
[Music]
[Music]
for my camping area now this was nice
hey tyler phillips
that might not go on treatment
yeah i know if only we could live an
animal crossing
hey i'm going for a walk in the woods
see you tonight and i'll be
a hundred thousand bells
more rich just from
shaking some trees but don't forget to
[Music]
see the truth
hello
i know in the field it's what happened
to me when jamie and i did the heavier
version of sweater it was like
much stronger singing than i'm confused
oh no i no one picked that up oh yeah i
have a new villager moving in tomorrow
it's pretty exciting it's a cute little
hipster hamster
[Music]
it sounds like a lot of you played this
game when you were younger as well
but it how it holds homes it holds a lot
of um fun memories for me
especially bruce's cafe
[Music]
oh hey sidnator sorry i didn't see you
there and diamond
[Music]
oh
[Music]
bye
oh yeah so there's not much over here
oh it's just going to be a little like
stargazing spot really
and a bit of sustainable enemy you know
because
but yeah it's not really much going on
how did i do
what
how did i even
[Music]
hey shasta thank you you're new welcome
[Music]
when i saw that the new animal crossing
update had
so if you just
put up with me doing my daily routine
we'll get to the fun stuff
oh yeah i've got to do
three tiny
[Music]
my campfire look at my cute little
little play thing
by the dog food
i don't have a dog so i
[Music]
no worries braggy thanks for coming
hope works okay for you
thanks for subscribing shasta
here is my little
oh i need to clean this
[Music]
but i need to make a ledge up to it
right now
[Music]
see i have this whole space massive
space i don't know what to do with it
i've just put a skeleton up here also i
was going to be
fancy and do one of those
uh what they're called like illusions
but it looks like there's a tiny town
down there
there's a spider down there tarantula
down there
oh my gosh that was actually scary
um
but i think actually i'm just going to
use it for something i'm not quite sure
what yet but maybe for
like farming might be nice down here
just because it's a bit out of the way
let's
gotta figure all this all this out
let's go get that tarantula
[Music]
as you can see i've still got a lot of
my halloween decorations around
[Music]
okay let's go get that
[Music]
we saw him
[Music]
no he's gotta be around here we saw him
[Music]
excuse me
if i get
hit by this toronto
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
so the other day i decided i should
probably be nicer to my villagers and
give them
um most random item on my island well
probably actually i'll show you in a bit
it's something that it's massive and i
don't know where to put it but i love it
i'll show you in a bit
um yeah so they're again they're getting
their own little gardens uh i haven't
done much with them i've just given
cause this one is caesar the um eighth i
think so i gave him a little monster of
plants uh this one oh this is the last
item here felt quite bad
[Music]
eugene here because he doesn't have the
biggest garden but
i think you know maybe we can make it
work that kind of goes to this house so
i'll just put that there for now so at
least he has something
[Music]
[Music]
i love it when he wears this little
skeleton outfit
i don't want
i want
[Music]
though he's like a really cool detective
dude
[Music]
bye
i want to buy a cardboard seat for him
to sit on
[Music]
i love these
[Applause]
oh my gosh that's so cute i want them
absolutely everywhere
i actually didn't know you could do that
[Music]
wow
[Music]
okay this is kind of like my mess of a
magic garden
[Music]
like this is quite random too i guess
very subtle
[Music]
the only thing is i don't know quite
know what to do for these people because
unfortunately
i made them like a little village
where they can all live in harmony but
i'm thinking i still need to
i have been saving up bits to do like an
outside cafe bit
and i'll either do it here
oh yeah here's the most probably awkward
thing or weird thing in the island is
this carriage
it just does not belong here but it's
freaking awesome but i don't know what
to do with it so i just leave it here
for now and we'll figure out what to do
um
probably put it in my spooky
woods back there or something
but yeah i'm either gonna have my little
cafe down here
and i've been saving up loads of stuff
for it or i'm gonna have it on the
other the
raised area uh up to the left however
they hang out more here so it'd be kind
of cute to make a little cafe area here
and see them use it
uh but it's not as big as the other
[Music]
but i ones need to make all of these
girls with their own little community
space for them to do stuff
hey tyler
i'm i'm using restream and it types out
emojis and it says that tyler phillips
it has given me elbow cough
chill w cat and take out
yes
don't know what those emojis
[Music]
oh ava okay cool
[Music]
oh yeah i don't know if i got that
fish before so i was gonna
see if i can give it to you
[Music]
that's his name right i think so i think
so
i don't think we expected that to be an
elbow
[Music]
try to get out of the plane
[Music]
it looks like someone dabbing and i walk
off ah i guess
yeah
because it was probably some boomers who
did the emoji and didn't realize that
make yourself comfy oh yeah
want all of her books like i want her
bookcase i want her to give me her
bookcase
give me a bookcase because i want it for
my cafe
okay
i think i know what to do with this
tricycle
i'm gonna put it in my little
kitty
thing
all these kids popping into their elbows
it's very trendy nowadays
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
yes i'm going to put the tricycle
oh i probably got one ah i'll just set
it then
[Music]
oh so many stars
oh yeah okay we're definitely gonna go
there don't you worry we're gonna go
somewhere
oh
[Applause]
i already know it okay let's go sell
some stuff
[Applause]
[Music]
for those who are afraid
[Music]
that looks like a nice sofa
there's nothing really new here though
[Music]
okay let me sell
the tricycle as well
[Music]
by accident
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
the outside
diy for guinness
oh this is new basic cooking recipes
cooking
everybody
[Music]
and then ladder setup kit recipe which
is gonna be
weta p which is going to be really good
[Music]
[Music]
oh no no no i don't need it again i
don't need it
[Music]
what
oh
okay
so many things
[Music]
hey arnold
hello
[Music]
what who has neferti or raymond or shino
against
ah
not me
maybe someone in the chat does i don't
have any of those stories
wait do i have raymond
no i don't think so it seems like you're
interested in devil's pose
[Music]
yes
[Music]
but if you
are looking for a villager can't you
just get the amiibo card or they are
they not
on the
[Music]
cards or not
[Music]
and the new ones are actually
[Music]
okay
[Music]
next stop
is
[Music]
hey masha
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone loves roman guys flashbacks
[Music]
thanks for following tardis509
[Music]
you see there is a matter which
ever perhaps you could help me
when i hit up on the idea
[Music]
a friend of mine who also happens to be
an experienced catholic
unfortunately it seems he's closed up
sharp and nobody appears to know where
he's gone
i also caught wind of a newly announced
group of
oh my god i forgot about this from the
update the little like giant guy roach
like little like weird people
but the gyros you see
in much the same way as i do
very wings that brewster has heard about
these diamonds
i would like you to take up the
searching booster
hell yes give i can do this
[Music]
the gyros i mentioned earlier were all
found on the island near where captain
leads his tours
on the islands
i'm sorry to bring you with this no
don't apologize
but i hope you know
uh you have my every confidence
good luck
thank you
[Music]
don't you i
i even put him in the thumbnail i was
really hoping to go to the cafe today
but this is fine i can work i can work
for him i can work
uh i just remembered something i wanted
to tell him
to celebrate the completion of our
collections yeah
because we completed all of the um
the
fossils
we complete completed our fossil
collection climb the rig yes what climb
the ring
happens
i show my gratitude to everyone for
pitching in to grow this world-class
museum i mean
it was just me
but sure let's let's say the rest of the
island is hell
just imagine it
an entire wing of this magnificent
museum captured in the singer
actually
i have a poster for you right here
[Music]
let's have a look at these posters
i want to make some money
[Music]
just one time he decides to purchase it
for his personal collection that would
be such a shocker
uh
yeah i think
so this is where the cafe is going to be
here
bye
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
whenever i make that
slowly
building some sort of
item collection because i feel like i
need so much more stuff i can't believe
how much some people have on their
islands it's crazy
[Music]
i mean i did stop playing this for a
very long time i already started
literally around christmas again
and then we had the announcement at the
update and i was like oh good good news
that i started doing this again oh yeah
we need to go and upgrade our app okay
we'll do that now
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
let's go and upgrade this app
hi i really love you what a lovely name
what is your vision do you mean like
university
here we call them diplomas
um but i graduated a while ago now like
a couple of years ago
it was computer game art and design
[Music]
[Music]
you know what though i have been toying
with the idea of actually going back and
doing a masters
i miss learning so much and just having
the time to like create something that
is yours
it's nice
if you're in uni make the most of it
honestly make the most of it
[Music]
my major is ai oh that sounds really
interesting
[Music]
okay
geez
there's a lot of new stuff here
oh
[Music]
okay
geez what do we want first
island life 101 services
details installs our own life it seems
tips as you begin each day's new
activities
i don't really need that
be a chef
yeah i probably want this there's a pro
camera take eye level photos with your
camera
using your new handheld camera and
tripod camera modes
sounds cool
pro decorating license
[ __ ] yeah custom fencing
new reactions yeah
top four fab hairstyles yes give me some
new hairstyles
[Music]
your order has imprinted
[Music]
uh
we have a lot of nook miles so to be
fair we could probably get them all
what does the donation box do
like do people actually
do will my villagers give me money
through the donation box
that would be nice probably not but that
would be nice
i don't know what this does but it
sounds very good
[Music]
now i can use accent walls oh and
ceiling items
okay
i guess that's kind of cool
i need a bigger house
[Music]
here's what we needed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't think it's big enough to cook
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i might as well just get all this
stuff
sorry if this is a little boring we're
gonna get it on then we're gonna check
it all out i can customize dancing now
there are no barriers to mixing things
up with colorful fancy
i wish this is one thing that
i don't know if they did it on purpose
but everything takes time and animal
crossing yeah you can't just multiple
select these things but yeah
they probably did it on purpose
i mean retention is everything right
um
custom designs patterns
you know i feel like i don't need these
now maybe i'll try this one
[Music]
[Music]
i have so
did they know many was just gonna go in
and quickly buy everything straight away
maybe
[Music]
we got any new things oh they got a
triangular topiary
oh a crosswalk sign
oh that's cute a little flower bed i
like that
a little bench i quite like that bench
oh
i love
this
that's quite sweet
oh there's so many of these things
yes
yes i love that
oh my god a volleyball that's such a
good idea
[Music]
that's so cute
[Music]
oh yes look at that sausage dog yes
oh wow oh my gosh
it's a giant elephant
oh this is cool
i want everything
oh
oh yes
okay
there's too many things i can't i can't
i'm just like guessing on everything yes
all right
what do i want
[Music]
i've already got a wind turbine ib it's
at the top
this is cute
[Music]
i want all the little all the little
like
uh
all the flower things yes can i please
just let me multi-select you're so
annoying
she's so annoying i want this elephant
though it's so stupid
oh i love it it's so stupid
yes
i'm gonna spend all of them on stuff
that's
what should we get
there's too many good things here
[Music]
i'm going to wake up to so much mail to
my own tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow
[Music]
oh yeah i love this
[Music]
nope
[Music]
[Music]
soulful okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
all right let's leave
do these have anything new to say
probably
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so i want to do the ordinances
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful early night owl definitely a
nice hour
[Music]
how is my island doing i know it's still
not great
uh
how is how is it doing
uh oh never mind i pressed it
okay bye i don't want to hear anyway hey
[Music]
okay so let's get back to my house drop
some stuff off and then we'll get on
that boat
we need to make a little
uh
a watering can hey tito killer thank you
for following
[Music]
oh my gosh
look at that stonework kitchen it looks
like a proper witchy witchy vibe thing
yes i want that
can i pretty good i could put i could
use that as like my cafe thing
oh yeah
is the dlc tomorrow that's a good
question tropical island i think it
might be tomorrow or friday this because
this wasn't supposed to be out
today well i don't think so
i can make it mushroom
um i can make the cardboard chair that i
want to give to eugene
um but yeah something something like
that so the dlc should be out
very very soon
[Music]
i came in here to make something but now
i'm getting distracted because i want to
see if i have enough mushrooms to make
this flooring that i want
where the [ __ ]
[Music]
that's the flooring that i want
i still don't have enough
what do i need oh i just i need one rare
mushroom how annoying
okay well i'm not gonna make anything
with mushrooms just in case then uh
well although it is a rare one so
that would look so cute on my door okay
screw it
[Music]
uh then we'll give my wreath to someone
else we'll pass
[Music]
oh yeah i was gonna make a water again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
photo framed fossil old sewing machine
oh
old sewing machine
where did i get that
we need to get back to the shop because
we need to buy that thing
[Music]
hey
can you give me a cap
i gave you the rock
oh
no
whatever i think i can buy it again
because i bought it once now so i think
it
is
[Music]
[Music]
up there
[Music]
[Applause]
no look
that's also the annoying thing about
animal crossing so easy to pick up
[Music]
[Music]
i'm back
[Music]
uh
i don't really want this
one last
[Music]
oh i got some new hairstyles as well
right we'll go back home we'll check
some stuff out
hey john
hey tito killer
how many hours have played this game
i don't even know
not too many
in comparison to other people why is
that why does that music change it's so
beautiful
um
because i played it when it came out up
until
for like a good few months and then i
stopped playing it for about
about a year
and then i started again around
halloween
and now we're here
[Music]
oh i love this music
[Music]
why has it changed
i love it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh thank you i'm glad you enjoyed the
halloween stream i i am still baffled
with how well that went and how much
money we're all able to reign
it's amazing
thank you so much again to everyone who
watched and participated in that stream
and gave money to a woman's craft as
well
it's very cool
no i want more of that lovely music
we're staying in here just to check out
those diys please say that the music's
still going to be going on
i like this
it's nice
it's just like closing time music that
they put on to let everyone know that
it's time for bed
um
um
[Music]
hey mike
[Music]
okay let's have a look at our diys
[Music]
is it just me who's really loving this
music
put your hand up in the chat if you like
this music too it can't just be me this
is lovely
um
big up to aenon well it wasn't a non
though because it was colin wasn't it
was colin williams
yeah very generous
instead of a work bench you'll need to
use a kitchen to prep these items
see how you how many diy licious
creations you can cook up
do i have a kitchen
is that what i could have made in the
new diys
the wheat where do i get all this stuff
from
colin
yes
i'm glad you like the music too
it is very calming sugarcane
okay well obviously you can get them
from bamboo
oh carrots
[Music]
okay where did we buy all this
i'm surprised i can't buy it from
the buy some seeds or something from
from here
[Music]
let's try this out
you can use this button to switch
between the camera types
this mood lowers the camera to eye level
making it to use it to take all kinds of
high impact
[Music]
move around
[Music]
oh
you look so cute
do something for me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
gotcha
i got you boys whoa
trippy man
[Music]
ooh spooky
[Music]
this is like how i would wake up if
they just kidnapped me
[Music]
oh
oh my gosh
hello
hello
[Music]
i love that
[Music]
where am i
oh hey hey boys
[Music]
this is so
silly i love it
[Music]
okay
so can i not mess it up
what separates programmer from the
average camera so that had more
filters
um and then you could never make like a
selfie
so you can never like hold the camera
and then do what i just did basically it
was always just you had like it was kind
of like hey let me get up here it was
always just kind of like
what you can see here
and then you just took a picture from
like this level you could never get down
to eye
level um
yeah so i can just buy flowers by the
looks of it
i can't buy
seeds
which i was thinking maybe i could do
i need to leave because these boys gonna
kick me out there shop soon
[Music]
okay well i need to go home anyway
bye boys see you later thanks for the
photos
[Music]
[Music]
give me back my sofa
[Music]
[Music]
i want to check out the new hashtag
[Music]
ink accent walls oh yeah
you can hang a different type of
wallpaper on one of the walls in a room
to create an accent wall
well i'm definitely very jews
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i might try
[Music]
[Music]
how do i do an accent
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
um
[Music]
maybe i may
oh i don't know
like
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
oh i see so it's the wall that you're
facing that becomes the accent wall okay
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's quite nice too okay let's just
have this
yeah okay
what kind of ceiling
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
well that's quite cool maybe not in this
room though or maybe over there by the
kitchen
[Music]
is riveting gameplay
[Music]
over here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
stay in this boat
[Music]
[Music]
makes sense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now let's go check out these new hatties
[Music]
we will get on this boat eventually okay
people
[Music]
yeah change up my look and then maybe
we'll take off this uh
this
bag but let's just see what kind of new
hairstyles we have to play around with
oh she actually looks so cute
a little short hair but that's not new
uh okay so these ones are new
what's this
that's quite cute
that's quite cute i do quite like that
one
i know that once was in the last update
oh you can have bowls as well
i do quite like this
and a big sugar sugar hair
or a little little bun
i quite like this one let's try this one
[Music]
take off the bag of shame yeah we're
going to take up the bag of shame
and uh just quickly put on
do i have like a little sailor's outfit
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a witchy sailor
[Music]
we don't you know what i never wear
shorts in this game because i don't like
them i think
well actually they actually don't look
too bad okay i take it back some of them
are very nice but some most of them are
absolutely horrible
and i don't like wearing them
[Music]
sure
oh i'm still wearing my bag of berries
off with bag of shame
keeping the bag of berries
let's go on a voyage and see what we can
find hopefully we find some
little
seeds so we can start growing some food
and um
we can
play around with all that because i
don't know where you get those right now
[Music]
let's just put my mushrooms
[Music]
[Music]
can i just say that this stream is ideal
for unwinding after a long day oh
thanks sidney i'm bad i mean if you like
this i can always do more animal
crossing streams
it's quite like mundane stuff
you know it's
not like the horror game streams
but
[Music]
can also help you
that's right
yeah i might do that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing there a little bit
dodgy russia not gonna lie a little bit
dodgy where's right
it's okay i don't want it
[Music]
actually kind of cute okay
all right
let's go on this box
uh before i go on i'm just gonna like
chuck my
stars here because i want some more
inventory space
i'll come back
[Music]
oh my god sounds like a janna
me tours go to places you can only reach
with me balls
okay
now
um
jenner
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me me
[Music]
no i don't guess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was so cute
oh i love that
um
[Music]
explanation
[Music]
[Music]
hey who is this
a money tree
[Music]
it's him
[Music]
we found him already i thought it was
going to take ages i thought i had to
like
find oh my god there's so many money
trees around here
i think it's gonna take so much longer
than this to find him
maybe we'll get to go to the cafe today
oh probably not i might have to wait
like a day for it to be built or
something but
they've already set up little jumping
blocks
oh fragments okay so you need to get
a bunch of them to make a full one
that's fine by me
[Music]
[Music]
i just had parents evening talk to
non-stop for hours so this is nice and
chill
oh man yeah i can imagine that can be
pretty draining
hopefully most of the
kids
you
work with are like nice so you didn't
have to tell any parents any bad news
i'm glad you're going to chill now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh my gosh we have so much to do because
i just remember we have to go to that
other island as well okay
[Music]
thank you very much
hey
[Music]
hello sir
i see you i see you looking at me
and i'm looking at you
i can't run away from you
[Music]
i'm on an island from one of those boat
stores and it's full of money trees
and look it's rooster
[Music]
who's your rooster
you don't bruise them
um
[Music]
no no no no no no you're supposed to
come back with me so just
ghost me now
you are coming okay
okay okay okay i'll go back i'll go back
to that love you can't wait to be here
sipping coffee with you bye
enjoy the island
[Music]
anyone wants
to chat about any topics when we fish
any
burning
questions or any
any topics you have
hey moss
i i didn't get that fish died
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
i wonder if i can open it
no that's so rude
wow that's a big fish
i was about to turn off my pc but i saw
that smile on the thumbnail i had to
enter and leave a like at least ah
thanks autumn red
i appreciate it
very big smiles for the new animal
cooking update today it was much needed
come on
big fish
notice my bait i don't want to
accidentally get the small fish
i want to fix the process come on
no what now you're facing the other way
[Music]
okay
see me
see me
see it see it see it see it go for it go
for it go for it go for it see it see it
go for it
i saw it
oh my god
i didn't think i just go for it like
straight away
usually take a few nibbles first
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's just go back
oh another big one let's try and get
this big
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
come on that's right in front of your
bloody face
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
subconscious marketing
[Music]
[Music]
me when i watched what was that episode
five of swing games oh my gosh the sad
episode of good game i cried my little
heart out and i couldn't stop crying
so sad
why can't you write lyrics he's good in
this i know it's so heartfelt so
relatable as well
thanks for that
okay
[Music]
you want a jagman cover of the weird
weird sailor man's
song i mean it does sound like it's just
a ukulele being played so i could
probably find at the course that would
be weird
[Music]
definitely this one
should i keep that chest and we'll keep
it for now
okay i'm going to give my
uh
fish to the fish
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
right
[Music]
let's quickly do this
[Music]
that is last new jamie
[Music]
[Music]
the fish and the streams are just so
annoying sometimes
it's so cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
think it is
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
we are pretty
[Music]
oh
full
lush partition that sounds cute
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much
[Music]
okay now what we've got
we need to give that to ava
we have these little boys
that we can put in the ground
[Music]
[Music]
please pick up the right thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
apparently it will help
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
[Music]
i
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
see what happens
is
[Music]
island
i think that's the last thing we can
probably do today
oh no no i need to go back to the museum
[Music]
oh you're like princess peach
it's a dessert princess dress princess
peach that's so cute i love it
[Laughter]
princess peach as a rooster
[Music]
how are you doing
[Music]
we just found rooster on a little island
and now we're going to go back to the
museum
[Music]
[Music]
so that's what we're doing
i'm good thank you very good once i saw
that this
update was out early
but i've just recently gotten back into
this again
[Music]
news to brothers that we found
i keep getting their names mixed up
[Music]
what what's it called against
he said i hear you he said i get it i
don't know i think he said i hear you i
can't
[Music]
oh yes don't you worry i'll be there so
that'll be saturday perfect i'll be
there
don't worry
i'm i'm stupidly excited just to go back
in the cafe and have a cup of coffee
[Music]
cakey slider or anything
okay now we're gonna go to halves island
and check out the changes on
[Music]
oh there i don't need a ticket to go to
house island
oh
[Music]
ah
nintendo are really good at just putting
in quick
features like little details that really
make things
hey tom
i'm checking out the new animal crossing
update i was so excited when i heard
about it i'm on harvest island now
[Music]
um
[Music]
they most likely cannot call me that
half
and you can call me that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to live
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh cute
i thought i thought jenny would be
excited for this too i literally like
went on the computer for work and then i
saw twitter just saying the update was
out one day early and i was like what
i just knew i had to update it straight
away
don't ya
[Music]
hell yes
[Music]
[Music]
is
there are models
weird things
nope that's
[Music]
of course i knew lloyd
uh yes death we're going to play alan
wake next week we're supposed to play
today but i was like
i need to play animal crossing so yeah
we'll play it next week
[Music]
talented husband and wife furniture
refurbishing team
oh no i'm not gonna have enough bells
for all of these things
this is fine more things to save up for
again
what are you then
voting expert with the greenest of
thumbs up
[Music]
[Music]
legitimate art dealer or legitimate uh
taylor
[Music]
i mean eventually yes but we're not
friends
[Music]
is
[Music]
mysteriously accurate fortune teller oh
i mean that sounds useless but i want it
i want it
okay we're gonna turn it a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
will give you access to your home
storage what
i have access to my home storage or do
you mean outside of my home that could
be
very easy
[Music]
okay
let me give you the money
hey chloe i believe that gyro and had a
mustache and as such all art
all art dealings they do are legitimate
or because of the mustache i mean
perhaps but the person that they're
bringing in
if they are who i think they are they do
not have a mustache so
out goes that logic
yeah
i want to donate to this one too
[Music]
i quite like the sound of this one
i'll give you a little bit
it's not a world i want to live in
i'm running out of money first
okay that's it that's all you're getting
on me i don't have much else
i did my best
[Music]
oh i think my favorite part in all of
this was just
the boat ride it was so cute
i loved it
the boat ripe was so cute
i might go on another one but i'm
looking at the time
also hello love your content by the way
and looking forward to more spooky
playthroughs ah thank you chloe i'm
gonna play more um
adam wake next week so more spooky
playthroughs to come
best island you've ever visited oh man
[Applause]
i mean i visited
amy i haven't
because i stopped playing
so yeah i've only already visited
uh
amy's braden
uh
my friend luke's but i can't remember
that except once a long time ago
so yeah i don't have much to to go on
but amy's was very very good
[Music]
is
[Music]
train wreck pumpkin pie is according to
tango boxing is go
is important tango boxing is okay
yes
what was that go for liquidation
oh
interesting
yes back to orange town
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
how do i cook in the kitchen
i'm so confused by this
i need a kitchen where's the kitchen
[Music]
i have so many songs on my island they
choose to sing the spooky song from the
horror forest at the back of my island i
don't know why let me just walk around
singing spooky songs
thanks death
i was wearing a little nightmares outfit
earlier actually with like the paper bag
head and
and the yellow raincoat
it was really cute
but then i wanted to see my new
hairstyle hairstyle and then i went on a
boat i thought i'd be on captain
um
yeah let's craft see if i can
[Music]
[Music]
so
is
where is it
i add something here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so much stuff
let's buy all the iron things
[Music]
here
oh that's the kitchen i want it
oh
i just need more stones and i can make
one
wow that was easier than i thought
[Music]
let's get some steps
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm never gonna use this much
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it might take me a little while so
collecting i'm not a stone so i need
this is where i want to put my ladder
that stays there
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
the rainy i studied at farnam university
of creative arts but honestly if i if i
have my choice again i probably would go
somewhere else
um
[Music]
i don't want to be too harsh but i i
wanted to study i wanted to study a very
specific
course
that turned out to not quite be what i
wanted
so i had to change course last minute
i wish i could more investigation
so
yeah don't
just go to the university i want to
take a look around at once yourself take
a look at violin as well but there's
been some changes they've made that i
don't really agree with like um they had
their own art shop
that
obviously it was an art university it is
not universal
and second
from right here they're getting rid of
the art shop which means that students
don't get
discounted art
and not so much fun
so difficult even
housing
but yeah but if you like a present and
then work
it's good to talk to them about their
university and stuff but
bear in mind that university is an
experience and i think in any uni
there's good and bad and you can make
the most of basically anyone that you go
to not to say that you can speak to
anyone
um
but if you find that you go to one and
you like
to elsewhere or whatever like
at the end of the day
the best thing that uni gives you is
time
not to say you have lots of free time
but you have the time to work on
something that you're passionate about
and that will be yours and it's up to
you
how you use that time wisely like
one thing i
wish
i had looked into more was um
[Music]
looking at the resources
was looking at the resources about what
the universities offer you like for
instance
um
the pharma university that i went to the
library wasn't open on the weekends and
uh
also the library didn't have the
software that i needed for my games
course
so i could only use the computers in the
classrooms which are only open like on
certain times and at certain dates
whereas my friends who went to bigger
universities
got to like go and use the equipment and
computers like over the weekends and
overnight and stuff and we didn't get
the luxury of like having that
wow your bed really does not
does not suit this room
why did i give it to you
um
but yeah just lots of things lots of
things to think about
um and that's just the
bad part there were good parts as well
like i mean mainly the the best parts
about my uni and probably every unit to
be honest it's just the people that i
met with
i missed so much and i learned so much
just from my peers like it was a great
experience
hey connie honey ho connie here i'm
sorry if i'm saying your name wrong
in america
[Music]
okay tell you what let's just go to
one more uh hit the truck
we'll
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
yep
[Music]
again
[Music]
okay
[Music]
how many points
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i hardly um it why would i put rocks in
my storage
this
is okay
[Music]
house
[Music]
oh okay are you all ready to play
another game
i know the rules okay what what do we
think well let's let's see what cards
marcel pearls first
[Music]
higher or lower
last time we said higher but to be fair
the card polled was a seven
um
and we lost
should we say higher
again what do you all think
i'm waiting
i'm thinking higher would probably be
the best but you never know it could be
one two three
higher i'm gonna stick to my butt my my
buns and my cans okay
i love how our 133 is like obviously
higher
sad
i'm sad
[Music]
okay
it's okay
so what i would have said higher as well
ib
i'm trying to remember
where there were rocks that i might have
people
[Music]
yep
[Music]
how many rocks do i need
30 yeah
[Music]
oh wow
i'm just gonna check my storage and then
if i don't have them then this is good
night
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
i just saved and ended so i guess this
is good night either way
will i find the rocks who knows tune in
next time
when will i play animal crossing again
who knows make sure that you're
following me on twitch and subscribe to
me on youtube and that's your best way
of knowing
i actually really didn't mean to save an
end it was just kind of like a reflex
thing but we've done it now and i'm
sticking with it
[Laughter]
[Music]
i
am planning on doing some more twitch
only streams in the future they're going
to be very sporadic just kind of like
whatever you'll like them and i'm
probably just going to play a little
indie games because i really miss just
playing
games from smaller creators um and not
having the pressure of having to finish
like a long game
um so
if you want to see more from me please
do make sure you are following on twitch
i'm making this slow move over to
twitter i'm just kind of dipping my toes
in now
um
but yeah living on a cliffhanger thank
you so much for staying with me and
checking out
animal crossings new 2.0 update
i'm very happy i cannot wait for the
cafe very excited for the cafe um i have
a lot more things to spend my money on
now and i'm kind of glad that i still
have a lot of open space on my island
because that means that i can populate
that with all the new content that has
just come along now don't forget the dlc
does come out in a couple of days and in
that dlc you have a job
which is crazy thank you so much for
following
no way jose 85
but yeah in the dlc you have a job and
you basically decorate houses
for different types of villagers and
then from what i
gather from that you can learn new
skills as well and then take them back
to your island and implement those new
tactics and skills on your island which
is quite cute
but yeah
thank you so much for joining me i will
see you next thursday i'm going to go
back and play alan wake we started
playing that couple of weeks ago uh the
first video is up on my youtube channel
if you want to if you want to watch that
uh but yeah i'll be playing more of that
next thursday 8 30 p.m
i always say bst but it's gmt now
because the clocks have moved time has
changed uh yeah so i'll say goodbye to
who i can see in the chat
um
goodbye to ib196 goodbye sydnata goodbye
r133
[Music]
goodbye frank no
17
goodbye
no way jose
goodbye claim clayback but we're going
bye clay
um
[Music]
by death 157
back with alan wake next week death
by jan dio by emma
[Music]
and goodbye to anyone who i missed in
the chat
and goodbye to
anyone who is watching and isn't in the
chat as always i really appreciate you
being here as well have a lovely day
evening